l'audace de sortir du privé lucratif
cette période de la vie qui quand même
vous pouvez un minimum rencontre un
minimum de dignité quoi c'est vrai pour
les gens qui sont mais c'est vrai aussi
pour le personnel et soulevant ou s'ils
lui maltraités et mal payé donc on est
ce une alice vraiment tout ce secteur de
l'arbas si vous me demandiez faut qu'ils
aient un grand service public du grand
âge bien évidemment voilà et là on les
aura les outils de contrôle voyez là on
sera en vigilance pour corriger tel ou
tel comportement une telle ou telle
injustice faut avoir une ambition c'est
on leur doit quelque chose à nos aînés
quoi vous voyez on parle beaucoup de
dette la dette les packs économique et
financière elle est humaine aussi alors
dans ce cas le gouvernement a une
ambition c'est de créer une cinquième
branche de la sécurité sociale justement
pour lutter contre la dépendance et donc
à destination de ces personnes âgées
c'était un projet qui étaient annoncés
avant la crise sanitaire du corona virus
finalement il a été vraiment mis en
place en tout cas financer ça c'est un
échec du gouvernement bat d'abord il a
fallu quand même que cette crise
épidémique
pour qu'on reconnaisse un peu plus et
épate dans la société et qu'ils aient
quelques subsides accordés par le
gouvernement mais après il ya eu recul
parce que je pense qu'à d'autres choix
qui sont faits on a d'autres amis on a
d'autres copains on ad'autres coquin et
à partir de là on construit les réformes
à partir de leurs intérêts merci
beaucoup parce qu'il ya eu délit on
écoutera avec attention votre question
au gouvernement sur ce sujet réalisé par
année on va retrouver justement audrey
vue états en tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle du sénat audrey il y aura
beaucoup de questions de santé cet après
midi oui mais avant même d'entamer cette
séance de questions qui portera en effet
beaucoup sur la santé
nommage sounalet solennelle paravent
soir a rendu par le président du sénat
gérard larcher au brigadier alexandre
martin qui est décédé samedi dernier en
opérations au mali il faisait partie de
l'opération barkan ensuite la toute
première question qui sera posée portera
elle sur la situation en ukraine alors
que le monde scrute une éventuelle
offensive russe dans le pays emmanuel
macron a mis en garde moscou hier il a
dit la riposte on sera là à coup sûr et
elle sera élevée les sénateurs devraient
demander des détails à jean yves le
drian que nous avons vu tout à l'heure
sur les bancs du sénat le ministre des
affaires étrangères et ensuite vous
l'avez dit il y aura beaucoup de
questions en matière de santé question
du groupe communiste vous l'avez évoqué
sur la situation dans les étapes ehpad
sur la manière dont sont traités nos
aînés il y aura aussi plusieurs
questions sur la situation dans les
hôpitaux qu'en est-il de l'accès aux
soins pour les français après deux ans
de pandémie le groupe rdse a notamment
des questions sur l'égalité d'accès aux
services publics et à la santé mais vous
l'avez entendu la cloche va sonner la
séance de questions au gouvernement
commence avec un hommage solennel de
gérard larcher au brigadier alexandre
martin écouter
[Musique]
je n'en vois point
le procès verbal est donc adoptée sous
les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues et avec beaucoup
d'émotion que nous avons appris la mort
samedi dernier du brigadier à l'uc san
martin
en du 54e régiment d'artillerie d'hyères
il a succombé à ses blessures à la suite
de l'attaqué du camp français gao au
cours de laquelle plusieurs autres
ses frères d'armes nos soldats
ont également été blessés
au nom du sénat tout entier
je veux saluer le courage de ces soldats
morts pour la france en luttant contre
le terrorisme djihadiste ussel
et exprimer notre solidarité
envers les blessés
en notre nom à tous je veux assurer sa
famille et ses frères d'armes de notre
profonde compassion
et leur présenter vos pensées et nos
condoléances attristées
seconde d'observer un court moment de
recueillement en hommage à alexandre
martin qui a servi la france avec
honneur et dévouement
je vous remercie
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise en direct
sur public sénat et sur notre site
internet
s'appelle chacun d'entre vous a observé
au cours de nos échanges
le respect qui est une valeur
essentielle au sénat qui avait su qu'il
s'agisse du respect les uns et les
autres ou celui du temps de parole et je
vais donner la parole à notre collègue
michel dagbert pour le groupe du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant la parole
mon cher collègue merci monsieur
présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'europe des
affaires étrangères et porte sur la
situation aux frontières entre la russie
et l'ukraine
monsieur le ministre le conflit russo
ukrainien semble s'aggraver de jour en
jour et les tensions qu'ils provoquent
entre les russes et les occidentaux
deviennent de plus en plus préoccupant
hier encore la russie a effectué une
série de manoeuvres militaires
impliquant six mille hommes des avions
de chasse et des bombardiers à la
frontière sud et en crimée annexée ces
opérations interviennent après le
déploiement de chars et de cent mille
soldats à la frontière ukrainienne
faisant craindre une possible invasion
alors que l'ukraine est également
touchée par des cyber attaques ciblant
notamment plusieurs sites
gouvernementaux
les pays de l'otan ont pour leur part
placé des forces en alerte et envoyer
des navires et des avions de combat pour
renforcer la défense de l'europe 2 en
europe de l'est réunis en
visioconférence ce lundi les dirigeants
des états unis des instances européennes
de l'otan des pays européens dont la
france et l'allemagne ont réaffirmé leur
soutien sans réserve à l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine et ont évoqué
des sanctions très lourdes à l'encontre
de la russie en cas d'agression contre
ce pays
parallèlement aux efforts diplomatiques
auxquels la france prend toute sa part
se poursuivent avec les occidentaux et
ont souligné leur ziercke aux mains
d'une solution diplomatique de trouver
une voie de désescalade
la france a quant à elle pris
l'initiative de relancer les rencontres
et des discussions en format normandie
dans ce contexte monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous nous indiquer comment la
france compte l agir pour parvenir à
élaborer une position unique et forte en
union européenne capable de favoriser
une résumé une résolution politique à
cette crise
on vous répondent la parole est aux
ministres de l'europe des affaires
étrangères monsieur jean yves le drian
monsieur le ministre vous monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur dacbert
je ne vous cacherai pas que la situation
est sous très graves tensions
comme
l'a évoqué le président de la république
hier aux côtés du chancelier allemand
la russie se comporte comme une
puissance de déséquilibre
il ne tient qu'à elle de devenir un
acteur de désescalade
nous sommes totalement mobilisés
avec nos partenaires européens avec nos
partenaires américains pour enrayer
cette dynamique de l' escalade il faut
appeler les choses par leur nom
devrait insister sur eux la très grande
unité qui existe aujourd'hui entre les
27 qui se sont réunis sous présidence
française toute la journée de lundi à
bruxelles
l'unité aussi à l'otan les entretiens
que j'ai pu avoir tant avec le
secrétaire d'état blinken avant-hier ou
avec le secrétaire général de l'otan
hier montre cette force de l'unité sur
trois priorités d'abord il y aura des
sanctions massives contre la russie si
elle porte une nouvelle atteinte à
l'intégrité territoriale de l'ukraine
nous y travaillons
mais ensuite il faut tout fait pour que
le dialogue avec la russie soient
poursuivis et pour que nous puissions
contribuer à la désescalade des
discussions le format normandie ont lieu
aujourd'hui même à paris et je l'espère
d'autres propositions seront proposés
sur notre initiative à la russie dans
des différents cadres différents formats
où se passe en ce moment les discussions
que ce soit l'otan ont lancé oeufs et
puis nous devrons être aussi solidaire
des pays de l'otan l'union européenne
qui peuvent être affectés par cette
crise ce qu'on appelle les mesures de
réassurance et nous le faisons à l'égard
des pays baltes et dans les jours qui
viennent à l'égard de la roumanie nous
nous sommes dans une posture de défense
collective de dissuasion de résidence
européenne mais aussi de contribution au
dialogue et la présidence française est
totalement
mobilisée dans cette ces initiatives je
me rendrai moi même avec ma collègue
allemande dans la pieve dans quelques
jours est de nouveau en roumanie pour
assurer nos collègues roumains de notre
solidarité madame la ministre de
désarmer se trouve en ce moment à
bucarest également donc la situation est
très tendue mais nous prenons tous les
initiatives nécessaires pour embrayer
sur un processus de désescalade
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue jean
bernard magnier pour le gros socialistes
écologistes et républicains vous avez la
parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur misé du
question nationale mais j'ai bien noté
sur l'absence parmi nous cet après midi
donc madame la secrétaire d'état je
m'interroge sur la perception que vous
avez de l'état l'école dans le contexte
de crise sanitaire qui impacte
considérablement son fonctionnement
depuis deux ans même si
l'oms délégation nationale défend
ardemment ses réformes son échec à la
tête du ministère est pas tant la
réforme du lycée et raté son objectif
était de casser l'effet filière mais
elle a accru les inégalités sociales et
territoriales
au collège la démission constante des
postes pour privilégier les heures
supplémentaires a abouti à un manque
d'effectif considérable et des
remplacements non assurés en particulier
dans la période de crise sanitaire que
nous vivons depuis deux ans quant à
l'école élémentaire la grande réforme du
quinquennat le doublement de
dédoublement des classes de cp de sigean
en zone prioritaire donne des résultats
classés dans le bas de la fourchette par
les chercheurs
cette réforme étant très consommatrice
de poste vous avez ponctionner les
moyens sur un dispositif qui s'appelle
plus de maîtres queux de classe qui
donnait pour tendre à entière
satisfaction aux enseignants aujourd'hui
bien que les textes prévoient toujours
une semaine scolaire de neuf demi
journées
la quasi totalité des écoles de ce pays
fonctionne par dérogation sur quatre
journées en rythme dont on connaît la
nocivité pour les enfants mais qui
satisferait nombre de lobby
périphériques à l'école enfin rien n'a
été fait pour revaloriser sérieusement
les carrières et les formations des
enseignants aujourd'hui le métier n'est
plus attractif et nous courons à la
catastrophe pour les recrutements quant
à la gestion de la crise sanitaire
depuis deux ans elle est jugé erratique
irréaliste et inopérante par les
enseignants qui vous crient tous les
jours leur souffrance madame secrétaires
d'état comment le gouvernement pense
t'il agir pour rétablir la confiance
dans un retour de l'institution scolaire
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'état
en charge de l'éducation prioritaire
madame nathalie l image la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur manier vous m'interrogez sur ma
perception mais je voudrais vous
retourner la question je pense qu'elle
est elle et elle est biaisé monsieur le
sénateur vous savez le budget de
l'éducation nationale c'est le premier
budget c'est le premier budget de l'état
le président de la république sous
l'impulsion du président de république
et du premier ministre un secrétariat
d'état dédié à l'éducation prioritaire a
spécifiquement été créée puis dans le
premier degré monsieur le sénateur en
effet la priorité est donnée aux savoirs
fondamentaux et vraiment je m'étonne
quand je vous entends dire que
finalement nos élèves n'auraient pas
progressé notamment grâce au
dédoublement des classes de cp et de ce1
en éducation prioritaire je rappelle que
nous sommes également en train de
dédoubler les classes de grande section
et quand j'observe le résultat des
premières cohortes ses premières
cohortes qui sont aujourd'hui en classe
de cm1 et cm2 et bien non monsieur le
sénateur les résultats sont plutôt
encourageants quant à la réforme du
baccalauréat la réforme de la réforme de
la loi prohibe la réforme du
baccalauréat vous pouvez contester
monsieur le sénateur mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est d'écouter les lycéens
et les lycéens se sont emparés de ces
réformes est il la salue et il la salue
enfin vous avez pointé monsieur le
sénateur monsieur le sénateur vous
m'avez interrogé sûr mais préfère
l'attrait du métier la revalorisation je
vous rappelle qu'il y ait un grenelle de
l'éducation à l'occasion duquel nous
avons revalorisé tous nos personnels
professeurs et autres enfin je voudrais
vous parler de l'école inclusive puisque
bien sûr nous avons accueilli plus de
400 mille élèves dans nos dans nos
écoles et je m'adresse notamment à ici à
à sophie cluzel et je voudrais vous
répondre également sur les sur les
accompagnants crsh puisque voilà vous
avez pointé un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements je veux juste vous
rappeler que pour les investisseurs nous
les avons doté d'un statut et de
revalorisation là où sous le précédent
quinquennat il était recruté sous
contrat aidé et je remercie
monsieur manier vous avez quelques
secondes oui simplement son président
puisque nous sommes encore en période de
voeux et d'engagement électoraux moi je
souhaite pour le prochain quinquennat
des moyens pour l'école et une
revalorisation des enseignants mais
aussi
la parole est au président jean claude
requier pour le gros du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président à monsieur
le premier ministre
parmi les préoccupations majeures de nos
concitoyens figure l'égal accès à des
soins abordables de qualité dans tous
les territoires
quelle que soit la commission matérielle
de malades il pas acceptable que le
concitoyen plus précaires soit
contraindre l'ancien des joints en face
il y eut la situation sanitaire pourtant
la mise en place de puits vrai juillet
d'importer patients urgence 19 euros 60
risque d'éloigner l'avantagé des
personnes déjà fragile de l'accès aux
soins faute de pouvoir avancer les frais
près 3 millions de personnes sont
dépourvus de complémentaires santé sont
là selon la drees est susceptible de
reporter rosé à l'échelon or le recours
aux urgences est aujourd'hui le seul
moyen d'accéder à une prise en charge
rapide dans les zones sous-dotées agira
liste amis rural et en milieu urbain
plus largement c'est encore une fois la
question du maillage du chef subi la
santé qui nous préoccupe le président de
la république a souligné à la creuse le
manque de mai seraient disponibles en
jean une situation très critique loire
profondément inquiétante dans de
nombreux territoires ruraux entre 6 et 8
millions de personnes vivent aujourd'hui
dans un désert médical
faute de médecine de ville ou
d'établissements de santé facilement
accessible
il répond temps pour quoi faire pour
mieux articuler l'hôpital avec la
médecine de ville mais
prévient il est temps de casser le
cercle vicieux pour des territoires
base hémorragique reculer cette unique
perte d'activité
d'attractivité économique tous ces
facteurs s'autoalimente de coastal ans
une spirale négative qui paraît ne pas
avoir de seine tous nous sommes attachés
au principe de l'égal accès au saint
esprit de la santé aussi comment comptez
vous renforcer les politiques publiques
concourant à ce principe fondamental de
notre république
pourrait fondre la parole et comme
monsieur le premier ministre c'est le
premier ministre merci beaucoup monsieur
présent mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs se le présent riquier beaucoup
de questions si je fais permettre en une
je vais commencer par la première qui
concerne le forfait aux urgences qui a
été
instauré à partir du 1er janvier 2022
pour finalement merci de m'en donner
l'opportunité rappeler la vérité est
rectifié je rappelle j'ai regardé que ce
forfait je vais revenir avant tout gérer
leur expliquer a été instauré par la loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2021 entre en vigueur le 1er
janvier 2022 et ce forfait a été voté
par le sénat c'est dire si c'est une
mesure responsable de quoi s'agit-il en
réalité en réalité mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs vous avez bien fait de
voter parce que c'est une excellente
mesure
et vous auriez dû
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi si vous
m'écoutez si vous m'écoutez bon cette
participation d'abord ça concerne les
usagers qui vont à l'hôpital qui vend
dans les services d'urgences et dont
l'entrée à l'hôpital n'est pas suivies
d'une hospitalisation
ça fait déjà beaucoup de monde ça fait
déjà beaucoup de monde il y avait depuis
très longtemps
non pas une mais un régime un maquis de
participation d'ailleurs dénoncée par
les rapports parlementaires y compris
sénatoriaux auquel un
personne ne comprenait plus rien
tellement il y en avait certains étaient
très élevées vous avez donné le chiffre
de 19 euros 61 dans votre question il y
en as j'ai regardé qui allait jusqu'à
1000 euros
tout ça était très compliqué
ces forfaits c'est le moment de le
rappeler était prise en charge par les
complémentaires alors vous dites
évidemment pour ceux qui en ont une mais
c'était le cas avant aussi rien de
changé
rien de changé c'était très compliqué au
point que
cela s'exprimait au détriment des
hôpitaux qui avait des difficultés de
recouvrement là aussi ça a été établi et
ils n'en n'ont pas besoin donc en
réalité un l'impact pour les usagers
tout considérer de cette mesure de
simplification par rapport aux
participations préalablement demandé
fera que tous usagers confondues on va
leur demander - avec cette réforme que
ce qu'ils avaient avant c'est plus
simple c'est plus lisible c'est mieux
pour les établissements de santé qui en
assureront auprès des complémentaires
j'insiste le plus souvent le
recouvrement direct donc de grâce cette
mesure a été débattue ici j'insiste
auprès de vous les associations
d'usagers que vous connaissez tous ici
qui sont particulièrement et elles ont
raison
sourcilleuse sur ces sujets avait et il
ya une traçabilité complète donné un
avis favorable à cette mesure qui a été
voté et qui rentrent maintenant en
vigueur donc loin monsieur le président
de gêner l'accès aux soins
cette mesure est une mesure de clarté et
de justice et favorise au contraire
la vie de nos concitoyens les
établissements de santé
je vais donner la parole de notre
collègue raymonde poncet mange pour
l'europe écologie solidarité territoire
[Applaudissements]
d'après la cour des comptes la france
n'était pas préparé à faire face à la
cobi
bon en ce siècle pourtant annoncé comme
celui des pandémies pendant la crise
votre gouvernement comme tous les autres
qui vous ont précédé a poursuivi les
restructurations et des fermetures de
centres hospitaliers selon la dgt est
l'adresse ce sont 25 établissements qui
vont fermer en 2020 les fermetures
définitives de 10 se multiplient comme
les provisoire par manque de personnel
plus les mois passent et plus la
situation devient critique selon le
syndicat des infirmiers 7500 postes
d'infirmiers étaient vacants juin 2020
34000 en septembre et on parle de 60000
désormais au delà des chiffres la
tendance grave et là alimenté par un
fort mouvement de démission la fhf
souligne dans une enquête auprès de 300
hôpitaux que la plupart ne parviennent
plus à recruter plus de 13 cents élèves
infirmiers ont abandonné leurs études
depuis 2018 même mouvement chez les
sages femmes
la situation est si critique que la rs
ile de france propose désormais de
recruter des infirmiers ont cdd de 6
mois à 3000 euros plus une prime de 4000
euros une initiative irrespectueuse
envers les fonctionnaires hospitaliers
en place qui lutte depuis deux ans et
qui voit cette pratique s'ajouter à
l'intérim mercenaires quelle fuite en
avant faute de constater que son
changement radical du système de santé
le choc d'attractivité n'a pas eu lieu
suite aux ségur cette semaine voit une
nouvelle mobilisation des professionnels
que compte faire le gouvernement pour
prendre enfin la mesure de la situation
et stopper des mauges à l'hémorragie de
personnel pour vous répondre la parole
il faut se faire l'état en charge en
france des familles monsieur paquet vous
avez la parole merci à monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice poncet mangent les tensions à
l'hôpital ne sont sont bien réelles
elles ne sont pas nouvelles elles ont
été il est vrai amplifié par la
cinquième vague épidémique avec le
double impact des variantes delta et au
micron ainsi que les virus hivernaux
pour objectiver ces tensions dont vous
avez des coupes décrit un certain nombre
de de contour le ministre olivier
ferrand avait commandité une enquête
dans le résultat sur plus de 1100
établissements ont fait état d'une
baisse globale de capacités relativement
légères s'agissant des ressources
humaines cette enquête elle met en avant
un absentéisme très légèrement supérieur
à 2010 9 sur la période octobre novembre
une baisse des effectifs réels mais
cette baisse elle est liée à des départs
de soignants qui masque des réalités
différentes d'une profession à l'autre
vous avez cité quelques professions
concernées ces situations de tension est
long bien sûr des impacts sur les
services d'urgence sur les capacités
derval alors face à cela il ya des
mesures d'ordre structurel qu'il faut
prendre et j'y reviendrai brièvement et
puis il ya des réponses immédiates que
nous devons adopter d'abord avec un
doublement de la majoration des heures
supplémentaires dont le ministre a
annoncé la prolongation jusqu'à la moins
la fin du mois de février ce qui est une
juste reconnaissance de la mobilisation
nos professionnels de santé ces derniers
mois également en assurant une
mobilisation collective chacun devant
prendre évidemment sa part entre
établissements de santé public-privé
l'ambulatoire également à fortiori dans
cette période compliquée et puis nous
sommes particulièrement attentifs aux
tensions sur les services d'urgences de
pédiatrie de maternité vous avez cité
les sages-femmes et les agences
régionales de santé sont bien évidemment
mobilisé et attentive afin de mettre en
place les mécanismes de solidarité
territoriale nécessaire que vous avez
d'ailleurs voté dans le cadre de ma
santé 2022 et puis il ya des actions
structurelles vous avez parlé
d'investissements et je me permets de
rappeler l'effort sans précédent qu'a
représenté le c ur de la santé au site à
chaque fois les chiffres mais ils sont
bien ils sont bien réels c'est son prêt
de 30 millions d'euros 30 milliards
pardon d'euros vous le savez pour
revaloriser ce qu'ils soignent
réinvestir dans le système de santé avec
notamment 19 milliards d'euros en faveur
de l'investissement courant voilà madame
la sénatrice pour ces éléments de
réponse
madame pansement je vais
[Musique]
oui veut très bon ce monsieur le
ministre démontre que décidément vous ne
pouvez pas porter une nouvelle politique
de santé pour bojan pichat comme pour
les hôpitaux nord essonne vous
poursuivez les restructurations et des
suppressions de postes il faut une
réforme du système de santé radicale à
laquelle vous invitait les soignants dès
2018 que vous n'avez pas entreprises et
des perspectives nouvelles pour un
personnel qui vous rappelle que le soin
ne sera jamais une marchandise
merci sa parole est un autre collègue
emmanuel capus dans le groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
vous avez la parole
si monsieur le président
c'est désormais une certitude
l'inflation est de nouveau partie du
paysage économique
elle s'établit à 5% dans la zone euro
bien au-delà des prévisions des
économistes
heureusement le choc est plus modérée en
france la question ne porte pas sur les
causes de cette inflation personne ne
remet en cause le quoi qu'il en coûte ou
du moins personne ne l'a contesté au
plus fort de la crise quand notre pays
mobilisé ses forces pour lutter contre
le virus la question aujourd'hui ce sont
les conséquences à court terme et à long
terme de cette inflation
à court terme le gouvernement a mis en
place des dispositifs d'urgence qui ont
largement atténué les effets je ne veux
pas relancer ces débats nous les avons
déjà eu ici ma question porte sur les
conséquences à long terme de l'inflation
parmi les scénarii possibles
le relèvement des taux d'intérêts
inquiète ce risque n'a jamais paru aussi
élevé aux états unis le patron de la
banque fédérale a reconnu que
l'inflation n'avait rien de transitoire
il laisse entendre qu'il pourrait
relever les taux pour éviter une crise
sociale en allemagne le rendement des
obligations d'état à 10 ans à repasser
au dessus de 2,0 une première depuis
2000 19
il est donc hautement improbable que la
france soit épargnée
face à cette hypothèse notre pays a deux
atouts la croissance la plus forte est
l'inflation la plus faible de toute la
zone euro mais madame la ministre il a
une faiblesse sa dette publique le
gouverneur de la banque de france a
rappelé hier que le taux d'endettement
actuel n'est pas soutenable à long terme
la question est donc simple madame la
ministre comment évaluez-vous le risque
de relèvement des taux d'intérêt et
pouvez-vous nous rassurer sur la
capacité de la france à rembourser sa
dette pour vous répondre la parole et à
madame agnès prédire une alchimie
ministre délégué en charge de
l'industrie et la parole madame la
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur chaput poule signé
allez dans votre introduction la france
a deux atouts la croissance la plus
forte de la zone euro et l'inflation la
plus faible cette situation favorable
s'explique par une politique cette
politique c'est celle du quoi qu'il en
coûte qui vous l'avez souligné n'était
pas contestée mais surtout un permis de
relancer la croissance puisqu'elle à
préserver l'outil de production elle à
préserver les compétences yann a permis
de redémarrer
extraordinairement rapidement à la
différence de ce qui avait été fait en
2008 et 2009 où l'ag sont la crise avait
certes permis de sauver le système
bancaire européen b avait eu deux
inconvénients le premier c'est que le
chômage partiel était trop bas et nous
avons une saignée d'emplois massives à
ce moment-là cent trente neuf mille
emplois supprimés dans l'industrie en
particulier et le deuxième c'est que la
fiscalité va augmenter trop rapidement
et a bloqué le rebond croissance donc
nous avons appris 2d gestion des crises
passées et aujourd'hui nous sommes nous
abordons cette situation de reprise dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
alors vous avez raison vous soulignez la
dette d'abord moi je m'appuie sur ce que
dit l'économiste paul krugman qui relève
que la gestion de la crise en france
d'un point de vue économique et qu une
des meilleures du monde je m'appuie
également sur ce que dit l'institut des
politiques publiques qui dit que si nous
n'avions pas pris ces mesures la dette
aurait été de 10 points supérieur donc
en fait cette stratégie que vous avez
soutenu a été la bonne comment fait-on
pour demain gérer ce problème de dette
qui n'est pas souhaitable puisque 115%
du pib tout le monde aura compris que
c'est beaucoup
c'est la crédibilité c'est la
crédibilité de la gestion des finances
publiques
c'est le fait que les ministres des
comptes publics qui se sont succédé le
ministre de l'économie ont toujours fait
mieux que le budget qu'ils ont annoncés
c'est le fait que pour la première fois
dans cette mandature nous sommes sortis
du processus de déficit public
trop important vis-à-vis l'union
européenne cette crédibilité là nous
permet vis-à-vis des marchés financiers
d'être crédible et de limiter les
conséquences d'une hausse des taux merci
la parole est à madame la présidente
pascale gruny pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
président ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'économie même la ministre
ap le premier ministre a annoncé la
semaine dernière un renforcement des
mesures de soutien aux entreprises de la
restauration traiteur et événementiel
dont l'activité est impactée par les
restrictions sanitaires ces mesures
utiles les cependant sur le rebord de la
route de nombreuses entreprises
pénalisées à cause des effets de seuil
ou des conditions d'éligibilité trop
restrictives chaque semaine je suis
interpellé sur le terrain par des chefs
d'entreprise exaspéré par ce qu'il
considère comme une usine à gaz c'est le
cas d'un restaurateur en grande
difficulté financière mais qui ne peut
pas bénéficier du dispositif coûts fixes
car se situant juste en dessous des 50%
de chiffre d'affaires perdu ou encore
d'un traiteur exclu lui aussi du
dispositif bien qu'ayant perdu deux
tiers de son chiffre d'affaires mais
avec un excédent brut d'exploitation
positif parce qu'il a été contraint de
baisser ses achats et son personnel en
décembre même la ministre comprendrait
aisément l'exaspération et le sentiment
d'injustice que peuvent ressentir ces
professionnels qui ne comprennent pas
pourquoi le quoi qu'il en coûte ne
ruisselle pas jusqu'à eux
quelles solutions concrètes pouvez vous
leur apportez alors qu'ils s'inquiètent
un peu plus chaque jour pour leur avenir
et leur survie pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame la ministre
délégué chargé de l'industrie
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice grenet je vais
d'abord dire que le quoi qu'il en coûte
c'est non seulement des dizaines de
milliers d'entreprises qui l'a sauvée
mais c'est des centaines de milliers
d'emplois et en particulier dans la
catégorie de vous mentionner que son
hôtellerie cafés restauration et pour
avoir personnellement accompagner la
mise en place du fonds de solidarité
je peux également témoigné d'une chose
très simple c'est que l'argent de cette
soi-disant usine à gaz est arrivé en
moins de deux semaines sur le compte en
banque d'entreprises qui ne
s'attendaient pas cette réactivité de
l'état est d'ailleurs lorsque vous
regardez en comparaison internationale
nous sommes un des pays qui a été
capable d'agir le plus rapidement et
surtout de faire ruisseler ce quoi qu'il
en coûte au plus près des français
des indépendants en particulier
la deuxième chose c'est que vous
mentionnez les effets de seuil alors
vous prenez le cas de quelqu'un qui
aurait perdu un peu moins de 50% du
chiffre d'affaires permettez moi de
marquer mon étonnement parce que le
dispositif a été modifié et ses 30% du
chiffre d'affaires qui fait les faits de
feuilles donc vous voyez bien que ce
dispositif s'applique bien dans le cas
où votre témoignage que laissait à
penser que certains restaurateurs
certains cafés et certains hôteliers ont
besoin d'accompagnement et moi je les
invite à prendre contact avec les
services de l'état pour avoir cet
accompagnement et savoir très exactement
à quoi ils ont droit je ne connais pas
de situation parce que nous avons au
delà des mesures standard applicable à
tout le monde la capacité à accompagner
individuellement chaque entreprise c'est
ce que nous faisons dans le traitement
des entreprises en difficulté nous
pouvons établir des plans de
remboursement jusqu'à dix ans sous
l'égide du tribunal de commerce nous
pouvons le faire même en dehors de
l'egypte du tribunal de commerce comme
l'annoncé bruno le maire récemment avec
la participation de la médiation du
crédit donc je vous le dis très
nettement il faut que les pales les
professionnels prennent la tâche des
services de l'état c'est peut-être pas
naturel de demander conseil ou appui aux
services fiscaux mais aujourd'hui nous
sommes en position d'accompagnement et
notre boussole c'est de préserver
l'emploi et de préserver l'outil de
travail des indépendants show remercier
quand même la présidente
moi j'entends dire mais vous savez il se
serait beaucoup mieux en fait que ça
passe directement par les chambres
consulaires et les préfet parce que
effectivement aujourd'hui c'est du cas
par cas c'est de la dentelle qu'il faut
et n'oubliez pas aussi que là on est le
secteur de l'événementiel mais vous avez
aussi les pme d'industrie qui sont
asphyxiés aujourd'hui par les coûts de
l'énergie et des matières premières il
faut vous soyez à ses côtés mais
sincèrement décentralisée venez au plus
près du terrain parce que là ce que vous
me dites ça reste à paris mais sur le
terrain moi je peux vous dire que c'est
compliqué alors vous avez eu votre veste
au mois de juin nous espérons bien que
vous aurez la deuxième pour la remplacer
au mois d'avril merci
la parole est à notre collègue michel
canévet pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues je
souhaite interpeller le gouvernement sur
la mise en oeuvre du ségur de la santé
de nombreux rassemblements ont eu lieu
avant-hier lundi devant les parcs de
permanence des parlementaires
finistériens mais cela a lieu partout en
france de la même façon des usagers et
personnels des responsables
d'établissements et services sociaux et
médico sociaux viennent dénoncer les
incohérences de la mise en oeuvre du
ségur de la santé il est temps d'y
remédier et je vais prendre trois
exemples le premier concerne les
services d aide à domicile il a été
décidé d'augmenter la rémunération des
personnels pour les services gérés par
des associations à but non lucratif
pourquoi il n'en est pas de même pour
les services gérés par les collectivités
territoriales
pourquoi il n'en est pas de même pour
les services gérés par les organismes
privés lucratifs
deuxièmement il a été décidé d'octroyer
le ségur de la santé au service de soins
infirmiers à domicile
des mesures financières ont été allouées
depuis le 1er octobre dernier elles ne
peuvent être mises en oeuvre puisqu'il
n'ya pas les décrets d'application
pourquoi les décrets d'application ne
sont encore pas publier monsieur lemay
1er mai premier ministre près de quatre
mois après la décision et puis vous avez
annoncé monsieur le premier ministre le
8 novembre dernier qu'une conférence sur
les métiers de l'accompagnement social
et médico social se tiendrait avant le
15 janvier nous sommes le 26 janvier et
ne s'est rien passé qu'en est il
pour vous répondre la parole et
secrétaire d'état chargée de l'enfance
et les paquebots
merci monsieur le merci monsieur le
président mesdames et sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs
question monsieur le sénateur me permet
de faire le point sur les actions menées
depuis plusieurs mois par le
gouvernement pour soutenir deux les
professionnels de santé du soin dans le
cadre du ségur delà de la santé après
dix ans de sous investissement rappelons
le le ségur et de loin le plus important
plan de soutien à notre système jamais
menée par une majorité présidentielle
avec est une réalité c'est une réalité
vous avez beau le contester c'est une
réalité
avec les accords du 13 juillet nous
avons abouti tout d'abord une
revalorisation d'ampleur immédiat de
plus de 1,5 million personnel de santé
pour huit milliards d'euros par an dès
décembre 2020 les personnels non
médicaux les sages femmes de la fonction
publique ont eu une revalorisation socle
de 183 euros mensuels au moins et jeudi
au moins vous le savez car depuis 2000
octobre 2021 nous avons également
revalorisée les grilles des personnels
soignants médico techniques et de la
rééducation personnels médicaux ne sont
pas en reste d'ailleurs nous avons
fusionné les premiers échelons de
rémunération améliorer leur fin de
carrière avec de nouveaux échelons nous
avons mis en place des primes
managériale et revaloriser l'indemnité
d'engagement de service public exclusif
et puis surtout loin de l'idée selon
laquelle il y aurait des oubliés du
ségur qui est une expression que l'on
entend souvent nous avons je crois a
choisi en responsabilité de répondre aux
problématiques spécifiques des
professions concernées par une perte
d'attractivité car chaque profession
n'est pas confrontés aux mêmes
problématiques
c'est le fondement avéré la paire d
attractivité des métiers que nous devons
méthodiquement étendu sur une
valorisation à plusieurs reprises au
delà de l'ambition initiale du ségur
vous avez deux protocoles d'extension
avec les organisations syndicales ont
été signés à l'issue d'une mission que
le premier ministre avait confié à
michel laforcade pour les structures
sanitaires médico social financé par
l'assurance maladie puis pour les
structures médico sociales publiques et
privées non lucrative et puis il ya
effectivement vous conclut y ait là
dessus les chantiers du social et du mx2
médico social le 18 février prochain
sous l'égide du premier 18 février
prochain sous l'égide du premier
ministre se tiendra effectivement ce ces
assises des métiers du social et du
médico-social sachez que sur la petite
enfance par ailleurs il ya un comité de
filière que nous avons mis en place qui
sera compétent aussi pour parler des
histoires de rémunération de formation
de carrière de passerelles entre les
différents métiers vous voyez bien nous
couvrons bien l'ensemble des métiers
concernés par le soin de nos
compatriotes de notre pays ce que le
vote le groupe de l'union centriste
comprend bien que des avancées ont été
obtenues dans le cadre du ségur de la
santé mais il convient je crois de
répondre aux aspirations de la
population
je suis désolé que vous n'ayez pas
répondu à deux des trois questions que
j'ai posées pour ce qui concerne la
conférence il est effectivement temps
qu'elles soient mises en oeuvre car il
ya de réelles attentes sur le terrain et
nous parlementaires avant du mal à
répondre à nos concitoyens ce créneau
les avancées qu'on peut entretenir donc
il est temps que qu'il en soit agi
collègue pascal symbole de 10 pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologique devait la parole merci à
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adressait au
ministre olivier véran ministre de la
santé
aujourd'hui sans l' ouvrage les
fossoyeurs dans lequel l'auteur victor
castanet décrit de suite à une enquête
menée durant trois ans
la maltraitance organisées dans les
ehpad privé lucratif du groupe français
orpea leader mondial sur le marché ce
secteur est particulièrement marquée par
des dérives lucrative sous effectif
constant dépenses réduites et en
conséquence une souffrance au travail du
personnel soignant et accompagnants qui
se répercute sur les personnes âgées
comme sur les familles
cette étude n'est pas la première à
dénoncer la marchandisation de la fin de
vie et à quel prix mais chaque collègue
notre groupe le pointe depuis longtemps
par conséquent monsieur le ministre
comptez vous assurer un véritable
contrôle pour empêcher que ce type de
dérives ne se reproduise en particulier
dans ces établissements privés lucratifs
et dans quel délai
on vous répondra la parole et co
secrétaire d'état en charge de l'entente
des familles
merci monsieur le merci monsieur le
président mesdames et ses actrices
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur de propos liminaire soumis
autorisée d'une part excuses et brigitte
bourguignon qui aurait pu être vous
répondre également mais vous ne vous
cette dont vous savez qu'elle a
contracté le qu'ovide ne peut donc être
présentés puis et puis ensuite une
pensée toute émue que vous partagez je
pense pour les résidents et les familles
qui ont pu subir les violences qui sont
décrites dans les ouvrages que vous avez
mentionné que rien ne peut justifier
rien ne peut justifier si de tels faits
sont avérés ils sont bien sûr
extrêmement grave et l'ensemble du
gouvernement et je pense des
parlementaires sur ses bancs les
condamne fermement en ce qui concerne un
établissement en particulier qui est
cité dans l'ouvragé que vous avez évoqué
vous le savez probablement l'agencé
régionale de santé avait diligenté une
inspection inopinée en 2018 suite à des
réclamations et des signalements qui
avait déjà été opéré à l'époque les
révélations récentes l'a cependant
penser que la situation était bien pire
que ce dont nous avions connaissance à
l'époque et toute la lumière doit donc
être fait sans délai sur les pratiques
de cet ehpad en particulier la ministre
brigitte bourguignon a demandé aux
services de l'état de mener une enquête
flash dans les meilleurs délais sur cet
établissement mais les faits rapportés
pose d'autres questions sur lesquelles
nous demandons au groupe orpea mme dont
le directeur général a été convoqué par
brigitte bourguignon de s'expliquer dans
les plus brefs délais là aussi au delà
de cette situation particulière je
rappelle que pour soutenir l'ensemble
des soignants et des provinciales des
établissements accueillant des personnes
âgées le gouvernement avait agi dès le
début du quinquennat dès 2018 nous avons
installé une commission nationale pour
de la lutte contre la maltraitance et la
promotion de la bientraitance qui
rassemblait nombreux experts elle a
remis ces travaux gouvernement l'année
dernière permettant d'aboutir à une
démission d'un maltraitante plus précise
et transversales aux âges à l'autonomie
au handicap elle existe est peut-être
avant madame la sénatrice mais toujours
est il que cette définition la
maltraitance est désormais inscrite dans
la loi dans le cadre du projet de loi
sur l'enfance qui a été adoptée hier et
puis par ailleurs l'état s'est fortement
engagé en faveur des ehpad d'une part
pour moderniser un certain nombre
d'entre eux avec un investissement de
demi plus de 2 milliards d'euros et puis
surtout surtout pour renforcer la
présence de soignants dans les
établissements avec notamment 10
soignant supplémentaires d'ici à cinq
ans qui s'additionnent aux 10000 qui
avait déjà été recrutés en 2017 et vous
le savez il ya eu en urgence un plan de
recrutement de 40000 personnel de soins
dans ces établissements pour prendre
soin de nos aînés voilà monsieur le
sénateur monsieur savoldelli
oui vous nous dites sur le ministre rien
ne peut justifier mais vous faites quoi
fait quoi concrètement on vous parle
d'un problème systémique ça révèle une
crise du libéralisme vous apporter des
réponses ponctuelles il a fallu qu à une
crise d'une telle ampleur pour redonner
quelques moyens aux ehpad tout comme
aujourd'hui vous réagissez à l'actualité
d'une enquête vous connais nous nous
connaissons la détresse des personnels
confrontés à des dilemmes éthiques
inhumain entre rester dans un secteur en
manque de moyens constat pour prodiguer
des soins décents ou bien le quitter
alors même qu'on manque de
professionnels dans ses métiers le
business tout est rationnalisée jusqu au
rationnement des couches et des
biscottes alors que des maisons de
retraite sont rachetés par des
multinationales et des fonds
d'investissement le tout avec de
l'argent public et vous ne l'avez pas
dit un seul mot l'une des grandes
promesses d'hommes des mâles bellemare
on était de faire une loi structurant
sur le grand âge elle n'a jamais vu le
jour alors il nous faut un véritable
service public du grand âge les ehpad
dépendant des groupes privés qui se sont
rués vers leurs grilles aux dépens de la
qualité de vie de leurs patients doivent
être mis sous tutelle monsieur le
ministre l'état ne doit plus laisser
faire car les personnes âgées ne sont
pas des marchandises le grand âge doit
sortir du marché
[Musique]
la parole
est à notre collègue laurence garnier
pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre
nantes a connu le week-end dernier un
nouveau déferlement de violences
urbaines vous avez annoncé hier la
procédure de dissolution du groupuscule
d'ultragauche nantes révolter nous vous
l'avions demandé avec la présidente de
région avec la députée nantes c'est une
bonne nouvelle et je vous en remercie
alors je vous ai écouté attentivement
hier monsieur le ministre à l'assemblée
nationale permettez moi de vous corriger
vous dater le début de ces violences de
la loi travail c'est faux ces violences
ont débuté avec le projet d'aéroport à
notre dame des landes est depuis nantes
est devenue la capitale des
manifestations ultraviolente
vous avez cédé aux à dist en renonçant à
l'aéroport de notre dame des landes
vous avez donné raison aux ultra violent
et envoyer le message politique
irresponsable que la violence paye dans
notre pays
je rappelle également que 95% des
manifestations à nantes ne sont pas
déclarés ça aussi nous le dénonçons
depuis des années ajoutez à ça la
complaisance d'élus locaux qui encourage
l'ultra gauche qui défilent aux cris de
mort aux flics et vous avez à nantes
le résultat que chacun connaît monsieur
le ministre
ma question est la suivante pourquoi
avez vous attendu d'être à deux mois de
l'élection présidentielle
pour dissoudre un groupuscule qui
détruit nantes depuis des années
pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice madame la sénatrice ne vous
inquiétez pas
je remercie de m'avoir remercier pour la
dissolution engagées du groupe
d'ailleurs la première patiente qui m'a
félicité ses hôtes présidente de région
qui a salué le courage du gouvernement
je les imagine que ces deux concerts que
vous évoquez cela puisque vous l'avez
cité deuxièmement je voudrais vous
rappeler que nous avons attendu aussi
longtemps pour pouvoir prendre ses
dispositions parce que c'est la loi de
séparatisme qu'une grande partie de
votre groupe n'a pas voté qui nous
permet justement d'engager ces
propositions de dissolution je ferai
d'ailleurs constaté la sénatrice que
depuis que le soft en responsabilité et
u15 groupe ultragauche ultra droite ou
islamistes majorité musicaux a été
dissous et que depuis désormais que je
suis de l'intérieur sur l'autorité du
premier ministre les quinze jours
quasiment je propose une dissolution de
groupes qui parfois existent pas
simplement depuis la même connerie mais
depuis 2002 2004 2016 et parfois depuis
1995 donc oui nous avons tout à fait en
respectant le droit en appliquant la loi
votée après une discussion qui a été
difficile il couperait une autre groupe
madame sur la liberté d'association je
ne ferai pas leurs proches évidemment de
tout les exos tôt j'ai entendu ici mais
je suis bien heureux en effet de pouvoir
désormais avoir des armes qui permettent
aux mises intérieur de proposer des
dissolutions qui à chaque fois ont été
validés par le conseil d'état
quant au fait que c'est notre dame des
landes qui a fait naître des difficultés
que vous connaissez et sur le fait que
nous aurions cd je me demande bien
pourquoi nous avons eu ce dossier en
héritage qui depuis plus de 30 ans
n'avait jamais été règle non plus
madame gordini
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre la réalité vous la
connaissez vous avez laissé nantes
s'enfoncer dans la violence
les nantais ne sont pas dupes de ces
manoeuvres ils savent pertinemment que
vous ne raterez pas en deux mois ce que
vous n'avez pas fait pendant cinq ans
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue rémi
cardo pour le vote socialiste écologiste
et républicaine
merci monsieur le président madame hamm
east le constat est amer jamais les
tensions entre la communauté enseignante
et leurs ministres ont été aussi forte
cette défiance est le pire ennemi de
l'efficacité des politiques publiques
est là mais la ministre on vous a
entendu sur la soi-disante dérive islamo
gauchistes dans les universités mais
bizarrement on ne vous a pas entendu sur
le manque de moyens de celle-ci le
prison la république lui aurait trouvé
une solution merveilleuse faire payer
les étudiants il me paraît insensé de
penser que l'on va augmenter les moyens
et le niveau des universités en faisant
payer les étudiants outre les moyens le
problème est en réalité celui de
l'orientation l'inégalité d'accès à
l'information sur les filières conduit
un taux d'échec record notamment lors de
la première année de licence comment est
il possible de faire peser la réussite
des élèves uniquement sur le financement
de l'université sans rompre le principe
d'égalité c'est une erreur de penser que
la gratuité est le problème le principal
problème est celui de l'orientation qui
est intimement liée à un manque
d'information et à votre plateforme
parcours sup qui en est la preuve c'est
aussi pour cela que que l'on retrouve
toujours plus d'étudiants en première
année de licence madame la ministre ma
question est assez simple que comptez
vous faire pour l'orientation pour que
l'université soit un vrai choix de
carrière adaptées aux envies et aux
compétences de chacun je vous remercie
vous réforme
de l'enseignement supérieur de la
recherche innovation madame frédéric
vidal la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et sénatrice mais
c'est des sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
rémy cardon vous parler d'un échec
record dans le la réussite du passage
entre la première et la deuxième année
de licence oui je vous le confirme en
2017 nous avions atteint le record des
chèques et j'ai plaisir de vous annoncer
mais je suis sûr que vous l'aurez
remarqué que nous avons augmenté de 10
points le taux de réussite de passage
entre la première et la deuxième année
de licence
mais ce sénateur vous dit que ce qui est
important c'est d'être capable de mieux
financer
université c'est la loi orientation et
réussit il me semble qu'elle n'a pas été
voté par cette partie du sénat c'est
plus un milliard d'euros exclusivement
pour le premier cycle c'est la loi pour
la recherche plus 25 milliards d'euros
alors vous m'avez reprocher le fait que
ce soit trop peu bien moi je pense que
c'est déjà ça et je vous assure que sur
le terrain les gens commencent à avoir
la différence vous continuer à prétendre
alors que j'ai déjà répondu à cette
question que le président de la
république s'est exprimé à nouveau que
la solution serait d'augmenter les
droits d'inscription monsieur sénateur
je vous rappelle que depuis trois ans
nous les avons gelé ce qui n'avait
jamais été fait sous les gouvernements
précédents je vous rappelle que depuis
trois ans nous avons gelé les loyers des
crous nous avons gelé les tickets rue là
encore je crois monsieur le sénateur que
entre les fantasmes que vous essayez de
soulever envers notre jeunesse qui
croyais moi a juste besoin de sentir que
nous sommes tous à ses côtés pour
l'aider à réussir pour l'aider à
acquérir des compétences pour l'aider in
fine et à avoir un métier je crois que
nous avons tous besoin de dire à notre
jeunesse que nous avons confiance en
elle pour préparer l'avenir c'est ce que
ce gouvernement a fait et à financer
comme jamais depuis cinq ans je car
d'euros
[Applaudissements]
1,1 chiffres je voudrais aussi un un
jeune sur six a arrêté ses études voilà
voilà le bilan de votre quinquennat et
bien votre mandature un jeune sur six
est bon il va s'ajouter à ça puisque
voulez parler de chiffres puisque la
semaine dernière vous avez menti devant
les députés
article de mediapart qui date de dix
d'hier ah oui quand même la semaine
dernière vous avez menti alors peut-être
que vous connaissez pas bien votre bilan
mais ou alors tout simplement vous c'est
la méconnaissance ou l'incompétence j'en
sais rien en tout cas vous avez dit que
100 % des logements du crous ont été
rénovés et en réalité c'est bizarrement
c'est le crous rue un homme qui dit que
c'est pas 100% d
logement c'est qu'il a en partie qui
sont en cours donc c'est la fin du
quinquennat ce qu'était le votre
objectif pour le coup vous êtes encore à
côté de la plaque donc même si le crous
vous contredis c'est quand même gênant
jeu
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue antoine
lefèvre pour le groupe l'est républicain
bien si monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions
écrivait bernard de clairvaux le
bouclier tarifaire appliquée pour
contenir la hausse du prix du gaz est
quant à lui une véritable bombe à
retardement
pour nos concitoyens les plus démunis
mise en place dans la loi de finances
2022 pour geler l'augmentation des
tarifs gaziers jusqu'au 1er juillet ce
dispositif offre une couverture louable
face à l'augmentation de la demande
mondiale et la restriction de l'offre il
ne s'applique toutefois qu aux
habitations individuelles ou collectives
justifiant d'une consommation inférieure
à 150 mégawatts heure est doté d'un
contrat réglementé gaz bay un des
critères auxquels ne répondent
malheureusement pas les bailleurs
sociaux chargés d'acheter le gaz en
amont avant de les redistribuer à leurs
locataires les organismes hlm vont ainsi
subir de plein fouet la hausse des
tarifs et n'auront d'autre choix que de
répercuter celle ci sur les factures de
leurs locataires je ne parle pas ici de
augmentation de quelques euros à la
marge mais bel et bien de hausse pouvant
s'échelonner de 40 à 250 euros de
provisions de charges supplémentaires
par mois et ce jusqu'à la fin de la
saison de chauffe une ironie des plus
mordante lorsque l'on fait état des
engagements pris par votre gouvernement
pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat des
français la question monsieur le premier
ministre est donc la suivante dans quel
délai comptez vous revenir sur ce
dispositif qui s'il n'est pas rectifié
de façon rétroactive risque de mettre
une fois de plus à l'amande nos
concitoyens les plus fragiles je vous
remercie pour vous répondre
l'apparent décalage délégué en charge du
logement d'abord gonds
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur antoine lefèvre vous l'avez dit
nous avons sans attendre pris des
mesures fortes pour protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des français face à cette
augmentation importante des prix de
l'énergie on peut parler du chèque
énergie 100 euros pour 6 millions de
ménages qui s'ajoute aux 150 euros
versés normalement en mai on peut parler
l'indemnité inflation 100 euros pour 38
million de ménages qui vont voir leur
pouvoir d'achat soutenu ainsi et nous
avons effectivement décidé c'est une
mesure nationale très forte de geler les
tarifs réglementés de l'électricité en
les plafonnant à + 4 % et de geler les
tarifs du gaz la question que vous posez
concerne les ménages qui n'achètent pas
directement la gaze un fournisseur à
tarif réglementé mais qui sont dans des
contrats collectifs en particulier ceux
qui sont souscrits par les organismes de
logements sociaux ces organismes de
logements sociaux nous ont effectivement
fait part il ya quelques jours à peine
de difficulté sachant qu'ils ne sont pas
tous dans cette situation certains sont
chauffés à l'électricité au réseau de
chaleur certains sont avec des contrats
individuels pour les locataires qui sont
donc bien protégés certains achètent
eux-mêmes en contrats collectifs le gaz
effet contrats collectifs sont denses un
certain nombre de cas à eux-mêmes
protéger parce qu'un décret sur les
tarifs réglementés et dans d'autres cas
non sur tous les sujets qui nous sont
remontés fait les situations de
défaillances de fournisseurs de logement
social fournisseur de gaz qui n'étant
plus en capacité de fournir demande aux
organismes de logement social de trouver
un autre fournisseur et dans ce cas là
on est au prix du marché face à cette
situation bien sûr le gouvernement va
continuer à travailler pour améliorer
encore la protection des français c'est
un dossier qui est partagé entre bruno
le maire barbara pompili et moi même
nous sommes en train de regarder sous
l'égide du premier ministre les
solutions possibles pour que nous
puissions protéger tous les français
quel que soit leur statut au regard de
leur logement
monsieur lefebvre
oui merci madame la ministre qualifié ce
problème de malencontreux oubli serait
un bel euphémisme pour que compass pour
coupe pour peu pardon que l'on passe en
revue les cinq dernières années de
négligence à l'égard du logement social
entre les coupes budgétaires opérées
trois années de suite le doublement de
la tva sur la construction de logements
sociaux la très controversée réduction
des apl le ralentissement sans précédent
du rythme de construction et
dernièrement la désindexation du plafond
de ressources pour bénéficier d'une
réduction de loyer de solidarité nous
savions que les maisons individuelles et
est devenu un non sens écologique
désormais madame la ministre et
l'habitat collectif à loyer modéré qui
en prend pour son grade décidément il ne
sera pas exagéré de dire que tout au
long de ce quinquennat le gouvernement
est resté très problème avec le logement
social
[Applaudissements]
la parole à notre collègue pierre
antoine lévy pour le groupe de l'union
surpris
monsieur le président mais mis les
intérieurs mes chers collègues lundi
soir pire lui des fonctionnaires de
police affectés à la bts caisse de
marseille mettez fin à ses jours avec
son arme de service pierre à 22 ans il
était champion d'arts martiaux il était
très apprécié par tous ses collègues et
avait toute la vie devant lui avant ce
geste désespéré huit autres
fonctionnaires de police ont mis fin à
leurs jours depuis le 1er janvier une
hécatombe je tiens à adresser au nom du
groupe de l'union centriste
mes plus sincères condoléances à la
famille de pierre ses proches ses
collègues mais aussi avoir une pensée
pour tous les fonctionnaires de police
les gendarmes éloignés et des
surveillants pénitentiaires ont mis fin
à leurs jours ces dernières années à
chaque nouveau drame ou message du
gouvernement est une émotion sincère
mais après qu'est ce qui peut pousser un
ou une fonctionnaire de police à
commettre l'irréparable
telle est la vraie question qui doit
être posée le manque d'effectifs le
vieillissement des matériels ou des
locaux peuvent être des éléments qui
constituent ce mal être pourtant c'est
vrai votre ministère entamé une
augmentation des effectifs et des moyens
matériels à louey la police et la
gendarmerie j'ai eu la preuve dans mon
département et pourtant ce mal être
cette détresse sont toujours là monsieur
le ministre on en arrive peut être à ce
geste ultime lorsqu'on considère que son
travail perd petit à petit de son sens
malgré la foi profonde que l'on à la
justice et la défense de ses concitoyens
le jeune ministre boulet ou indiqué au
sénat quelles actions avez-vous et
surtout allez vous mettre en oeuvre
d'urgence pour mettre fin à cette
funeste série je vous remercie
pour vos réponses ma parole et à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur d'hormones à
monsieur le président c'est à tort
monsieur sather à mon tour je veux
évidemment
déploré et passer le message que vous
avez passé de soutien face à la détresse
évidemment des policiers qui se sont
comme les gendarmes d'ailleurs suicidés
depuis le début de cette année puisque
en moyenne vous le savez c'était le cas
l'année dernière c'est par dizaines
qu'il ya dans l'administration que je le
rediriger ces suicides souvent avec leur
arme de service souvent dans les locaux
des brigades de gendarmerie ou dans les
commissariats de police
alors j'entends ce que vous dites je
connais c'est le major de la promotion
qui est arrivé à marseille il faisait
d'ailleurs partie des nouveaux effectifs
de la centaine d'hommes en effectifs
qu'en avait envoyé à marseille il avait
choisi des quartiers nord il était
courageux le présent la république aussi
l'avait rencontré et il était plein de
jeunesse
évidemment son geste touche toute la
police nationale ses collègues de
marseille évidemment et posé question à
l'administration et qu'il dirigeait si
l'essentiel de ses usines monsieur le
sénateur et ce n'est pas pour les
minimiser évidemment ou un lien direct
avec la vie personnelle et non pas
professionnelle de ces personnes et si
le fait d'être policiers ou des
gendarmes et d'avoir son arme de service
malheureusement contribuer à des
passages à l'acte plus que dans d'autres
administrations
l'administration ne sont pas dédouané
par les drames que nous connaissons en
2019 son prédécesseur avait lancé des
moyens très importants pour pouvoir
lutter contre les suicides dans la
police nationale j'ai décidé de les
faire évaluer par une société un conseil
extérieur le directeur général de la
police nationale qui a la semaine
dernière à ma demande réunit l'ensemble
des syndicats ont décidé tous ensemble
ne pouvoir recruter une vingtaine de
psychologues dans les endroits les plus
difficiles de la police nationale de
pouvoir donner davantage de moyens
budgétaires et humains aux associations
notamment je pense l'association qui est
les policiers qui se suicident et leurs
familles mais également une cellule
policiers victimes qui permet à chacune
et à chacun de pouvoir contacter ans
dans la hiérarchie parce que ce sens on
lorsqu'on se sent mal indépendamment
même évidemment de la hiérarchie qui
peut apporter ses conseils c'est
évidemment une question très difficile
et très délicate et je remercie de
l'avoir posée soyez assurés que sans
mesure miracle gestion de faire le
maximum pour les policiers
pierre antoine lévy
merci monsieur le ministre pour des
explications mais les faits sont là ils
sont têtus malgré toutes les mesures
prises des policiers continuent tous les
jours à mettre fin à leurs jours ils
commettent l'irréparable c'est le signe
que ce n'est pas suffisant et qu'il faut
chercher dans leurs actions et mal
beaucoup plus profond
ces mesures et réside également dans
l'écouté dans l'accompagnement et force
est de constater que l'humain est
beaucoup plus important que le matériel
merci
la parole est à notre collègue stéphane
m'bia noire pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adressait au ministre de l'éducation
nationale
lundi dernier le comité de suivi de la
réforme des affectations en classe de
seconde pour l'académie de paris à
formuler une recommandation sur la fin
de recrutement sur dossier pour les
lycées henri iv et louis legrand au
profit d'une plateforme informatisé que
je peux te monde connaît afin d'être
depuis le rectorat a indiqué je cite
qu'il fallait faire évoluer le
recrutement mais y aller par étape pour
que ce soit acceptable par les
communautés éducatives au wac le
discours est un petit peu plus flou mais
le recteur
guerrero a indiqué de porc de pour sa
part qu'il fallait ouvrir le recrutement
à l'ensemble des collégiens et instaurer
des quotas de boursiers alors pouvez
vous nous dire si votre gouvernement
entend inscrire ses deux établissements
d'excellence dans un processus de
discrimination positive
pour vous répondre la parole à la
secrétaire d'état en charge de
l'éducation prioritaire j'avais l'image
oui merci monsieur merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur pieds
noirs je remercie effectivement pour
votre question qui me permet de répondre
sur un sujet central qui est celui de
l'égalité républicaine et du mérite de
nos élèves notamment par l'arrêt cause
la reconnaissance de leurs de leur
travail alors la réforme de
l'affectation du lycée engagé par
l'académie de paris comme vous l'avez
dit très justement depuis la rentrée
précédente 2020 2021 je tiens à vous le
dire dans un premier temps a déjà
démontré son efficacité
d'abord avec un renforcement de la
mixité sociale
j'ajoute par ailleurs et c'est un
constat monsieur le sénateur
contrairement à ce qui avait pu être
avancé il n'y a pas eu de fuite en avant
vers l'enseignement privé en ce qui
concerne les lycées henri iv et louis le
grand puisque c'est précisément votre
question il entre dans la procédure
parce que la situation devait évoluer
cette situation devait évoluer en effet
parce qu'il n'y avait aucun critère
d'admission qui est est explicité ou
barré mais alors que toute décision
d'affectation doit normalement faire
l'objet d'une justification en cas de
recours des familles
s'appuyant sur des éléments je précise
objective et monsieur le sénateur ça
n'est pas la fin de la méritocratie
scolaire mais c'est au contraire son
rétablissement dans les lycées
d'excellence nos objectifs sont clairs
en pleine cohérence avec l'esprit de
l'école républicaine
la transparence l'équité le mérite et
des lycées enfin potentiellement
accessibles à tous les élèves parisiens
sur la base de leurs seuls résultats
scolaires je vous remercie
mais si monsieur pieds noirs
madame la ministre votre argumentation
pourrait se résumer en quelques mots
cachés ces bons élèves que je ne saurais
voir en réalité je comprends évidemment
l'intention d'orienter de d'ouverture
sociale mais je réfute la corrélation
entre le statut de boursier et les
performances académiques d'un collégien
je déplore l'abandon des parcours
d'excellence dans l'enseignement public
et même aujourd'hui ce qu'on constate la
honte de nos élites qui est une étape
nouvelle dans la déconstruction de la
méritocratie républicaine à laquelle
votre gouvernement me semble-t-il était
si attaché au début du quinquennat
figurez vous que notre pays est fier de
ses filières d'excellence ouverte à tous
contrairement à ce que vous avez dit
quelles que soient les conditions
sociales et je fais confiance à titre
personnel aux professeurs pour détecter
et convaincre leurs meilleurs élèves 10
pouces d'y postuler d'autres pays aspire
à autre chose qu'une convergence vers
une moyenne d'indicateurs totalement
technocratique et la construction d'un
d'un d'un artificielle indice de
position sociale tel qu'il a été défini
notre pays celui des lumières qui est
tellement attaché au remplacement la
substitution de talent à la naissance
figurez vous qu'ils mériteraient me
semble-t-il la multiplication de ces
établissements d'excellence pour que
tous puissent y accéder et qu'enfin
office on fasse prévaloir le seul
bulletin scolaire sur toute autre
considération
la parole
et un autre collège au référé pour le
vole socialistes écologistes et
républicains
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le mois
dernier le taux d'inflation dans la zone
euro s'est élevé à 5 % sur un an et ce
n'est qu'un début sans être
statisticiens les français constatent
chaque jour un puissant la hausse des
prix de nombreux produits de première
nécessité le pain le café les pâtes le
sucre les fruits et légumes les prix
explosent en particulier ceux de
l'énergie et du carburant leucan a
augmenté de 25% en un an cette flambée
des prix impact particulièrement les
français aux revenus modestes les plus
fragiles ne territoires ruraux aussi
tous nos concitoyens contraints
d'utiliser leur véhicule pour se
déplacer pour aller travailler pour
répondre à la situation le premier
ministre vient d'annoncer le relèvement
de 10 % du barème de l'indemnité
kilométrique un pansement sur une jambe
de bois cette proposition favorisera
probablement moins de 5 % des foyers
français est certainement parmi les plus
aisés alors monsieur le ministre les
salaires stan les retraites sont
péniblement revalorisé de 1,1 pour cent
les prix flandes le pouvoir d'achat des
français est en berne que répondez vous
à tous ceux et toutes celles qui doivent
chaque jour choisir entre manger se
chauffer ou bien faire le plein pour
aller travailler
pour vous répondre la parole et cala
plus déléguer charge de l'industrie
madame pas dire une hache et vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
ferrer jeu d'abord excusé bruno le maire
et olivier dussopt pts qui sont
actuellement en audition à l'assemblée
nationale et qui ne peuvent donc être
présent sur ces bancs au regard des
trois questions auxquelles j'ai répondu
depuis le début de la séance la première
façon d'améliorer le pouvoir d'achat et
c'est la politique que nous avons mis en
oeuvre depuis 2010 cette madame la
sénatrice c'est de faire en sorte que
plus de français trouver un emploi et
c'est de faire en sorte que ces emplois
rémunère mieux ces français et c'est
très exactement ce que nous on fait en
créant un million d'emplois sur ces
quatre dernières années un million
d'emplois en faisant en sorte que le
taux de chômage soit au plus bas depuis
10 ans alors même que nous venons de
traverser la crise la plus importante de
ce siècle en faisant en sorte également
de ce travail paye mieux c'est ce
gouvernement qui a fait avec la prime
d'activité fait en sorte que un
travailleur payés au smic qui reçoit de
son entreprise un peu près 1270 euros
puisse être proche de 1500 euros en
rémunération nette et c'est également la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires c'est également toutes
les mesures que nous avons prises pour
accompagner les personnes aux minima
sociaux avec l'augmentation sans
précédent de l'allocation adulte
handicapé et je salue l'action de sophie
cluzel sur ses bancs donc toutes ces
actions elles sont payées vous
mentionnez et vous avez parfaitement
raison l'augmentation du coût de la vie
est là aussi nous avons agi nous avons
pas tardé pour agir mais nous l'avons
fait de manière ciblée nous avons fait
en sorte précisément avec le chèque
énergie qu'a mentionné emmanuelle wargon
de couvrir et le chèque inflation de
couvrir l'augmentation du coût de
l'énergie le col mentation du coût de
carburant nous venons d'annoncer mardi
dernier le premier ministre l'a fait
pour les travailleurs le fait de
bénéficier d'une augmentation du du
barème fiscal kilométrique tout ça ce
sont des mesures très concrètes et elles
se traduisent dans l'augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat en 2020 de 2,2 pour cent
pour les français mais comparé en
moyenne internationale dans un contexte
de crise massif de crise massive ou
autres pays où il va faire une très près
le prix baisse du pouvoir d'achat donc
nous allons continuer mais nous ne
pouvons pas nous satisfaire de la
caricature que vous portez pas d'affairé
madame l'ami jean temps votre réponse
mais moi je veux je veux des réponses
concrètes et nous depuis des semaines
nous socialistes nous proposons une
baisse de la tva à 5,5 sur les
carburants pour soulager les français
quitte à le faire de façon temporaire
car à situation exceptionnelle mesures
exceptionnelles
l'urgence aujourd'hui les accompagner la
sortie de crise des ménages de tous ceux
qui sont pris à la gorge par les hausses
des prix l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est
d'augmenter significativement les bas
salaires et en particulier le smic alors
ça ne peut pas être le poids qu'il en
coûte d'un côté et de l'autre que des
miettes voit même rien pour tous les
français qui voient leur pouvoir d'achat
diminuer au fil des mois mais
[Musique]
la parole et à notre collègue frédérique
puissat pour le gobelet république le
président ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre en charge du travail merci à
monsieur le secrétaire d'état de me
répondre monsieur secrétaires d'état
tout ça pour ça le 20 décembre dernier
vous organisiez une concertation avec
les partenaires sociaux sur l'obligation
du pass sanitaire au téléthon au travail
le 21 décembre les organisations
syndicales indiqué qu'elle n'y était pas
favorable
les organisations patronales faisait
part de leurs réserves tout affirmé
néanmoins être d'accord pour renforcer
le télétravail madame la ministre
elisabeth porn confirmé elle-même qu'il
existait un consensus sur le télétravail
et pouvoir compter sur la responsabilité
des employeurs et des salariés pour le
renforcer néanmoins le 28 décembre coup
de tonnerre vous écrasez la concertation
et vous annoncer aux partenaires sociaux
mettre en place des sanctions
administratives pour les entrepreneurs
qui ne respecteraient pas l'obligation
de céder travail dans la foulée toutes
les organisations patronales sujet que
ces amendes était une ineptie alors que
les entreprises avaient eu une conduite
exemplaire depuis le début de la
pandémie dans la folie nous indiquons
combien cette idée était clivante est
inopérante loin de nous écouter vous
allez continuer à jeter l'opprobre sur
une catégorie de français les chefs
d'entreprise mais surtout alors que
l'encré du projet de loi était à peine
sèche le premier ministre annonce et la
fanny télétravail obligatoires madame la
ministre du travail vouloir rendre la
main aux entreprises le 2 février
prochain donc monsieur le secrétaire
d'état merci d'éclairer le parlement en
nous confirmant que finalement tout ça
pour ça votre amendement sanctionnant
les entrepreneurs n'aura finalement été
opérant que neuf jours
pour vous répondre la parole et à l'euro
il travestit secrétaire elle est à
charge des retraites la santé au travail
qui oblige merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice frédérique puissat
bon
j'entends dans votre question
presque un petit peu
contrariété mais au final au final est
ce que est ce que ce sujet est un sujet
concret de la vie des entreprises vous
connaissez bien que je connais bien
aussi d'ailleurs et bien la réponse est
oui bon série l'objectif de cette amende
n'est pas de distribuer les âmes en
comptons distribuer des amendes parce
que vous êtes mal garé dans la rue vous
savez très bien comment font les
inspecteurs du travail comment font les
contrôleurs du travail ils font des
lettres d'observation je le sais bien
ils font des mises en demeure et il mène
une procédure qui est une procédure
contradictoire qui permet l échange et
cet échange si j'avais évidemment il n'y
a pas de mouvement de la part de
l'employeur au regard de ce qui est
attendu eh bien peut déboucher sur une
sanction administrative qui est une
amende qui a été fixé à 500 euros or vu
d'ailleurs à 500 euros de manière à ce
que les tpe pme soient considérés et
qu'il n'y a pas une pression financière
qui soit démesurée les avis de ces
entreprises est ce que je voudrais aussi
vous dire parce que c'est très
opérationnel cet amant ne vise pas
uniquement le télétravail dont vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure madame puis ça vise
l'ensemble des obligations opérationnel
de l'employeur pour protéger la santé de
ses salariés ça veut dire que ça peut
être aussi bien le fait de respecter les
distances de porter le masque de mettre
à disposition du gel l'ensemble des
éléments qui sont dans le protocole
c'est pas une amende télétravail c'est
la possibilité qui était donnée
lorsqu'on est arrivé au bout qu'il n'y a
plus de discussion possible entre celui
ou celle qui contrôlent l employeur il
n'y a pas une bouffe bande la part de
l'employeur de terminer cela par une
sanction administrative ou sauver sinon
c'est quoi ce que le pénal et on se
retrouve chez procurant la république
postes ouvriers je connais bien ces
dispositions de l'autre côté est côté
opérationnel je pense que nous avons là
trouver une solution pour qu'au final ce
télétravail soit aussi en terme d'équité
respecté par tous y compris par les
boîtes très nombreuses que je connais et
où de très nombreux chefs d'entreprise
ont respecté l'ensemble des prérogatives
données par le gouvernement
quels critères d'état mais finalement on
s'est bien de neuf jours dont nous
parlons neuf jours ça pourrait presque
paraître anecdotique si nice est à
mettre en relation avec les heures de
débats que nous avons eus sur le sujet
qui était un faux débat si ce n'est que
c'est à mettre en relation avec une
commission mixte paritaire qui n'a pas
été conclue vive alors que l'heure
serait plutôt à la recherche de la
concorde mais au delà après les gilet
jaune après les ruraux contre les
urbains après finalement les vacciner
contre les non vaccinés c'est les chefs
d'entreprise contre le reste de la
population c'est un nouveau clivage est
là il est de la responsabilité de votre
gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue françoise
dumont pour le veau péripublic
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
le 16 octobre dernier le président de la
république s'engage et je cite à
préciser avant la fin de l'année par un
décret du gouvernement la manière dont
les sapeurs pompiers pourront mettre en
oeuvre les douze gestes techniques de
secourisme et de soins en effet la loi
matra se reconnaît la possibilité
offerte à nos sapeurs pompiers de
dispenser des actes de soins d'urgence
qu'ils effectuent déjà dans les faits
tous les jours cette disposition est on
ne peut plus logique lorsque l'on sait
que 80% de l'activité désiste relève
aujourd'hui du secours à personnes or
force est de constater coup pour l'heure
ce décret n'a pas été pris ma question
est donc simple qu'attendez vous par
ailleurs les quatre rapporteurs du texte
à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat dont
je fais partie ont pris la peine de vous
écrire afin de rendre très claire la
volonté du législateur quant au sens
qu'il entend donner à ces dispositions
sachez monsieur le premier ministre que
si le décret à venir ne respectent pas
la lettre de la loi nous inviterons les
présidents 2,10 à saisir le conseil
d'état afin qu'il soit annulé et s'ils
respectent la lettre de la loi mais en
dénature l'esprit alors nous modifierons
la loi afin de rendre ce décret caduque
enfin je souhaiterais obtenir des
explications sur l'absence de
revalorisation des indemnités que
perçoivent les 10 lorsqu'il assure des
carences ambulancière à la demande des
samu là aussi malgré les promesses
présidentielles toujours rien aucune
difficulté technique pourtant puisqu'il
s'agit de modifier un chiffre dans un
arrêté mais peut-être attendez-vous
l'étude d'un cabinet de conseil pour
procéder à cette modification
on n'est jamais trop prudent monsieur le
premier ministre les pompiers mérite
vraiment mieux que des paroles en l'air
mieux que de la communication stérile
mieux que des discours de sainte barbe
il est grand temps d'agir
pour vous répondre à la parole au
secrétaire d'état en charge de l'enfance
et des familles monsieur taquet
merci monsieur le président dans mes
sénatrice c'est un terreau madame la
sénatrice les pompiers mérite mieux
aussi que sous-entendu ou d où des
propos polémiques et je vais m'évertuer
à répondre au plus près aux questions
que vous avez soulevé que ce sont des
questions légitimes et qu'ils qui
peuvent ou qui peuvent se reposer sur un
dialogue courtois et respectueux vous
dire tout d'abord ce sera l'occasion
pour moi de saluer évidemment
l'engagement quotidien de nos de nos
pompiers toutes les sept secondes en
france tous les jours une intervention
de sapeurs pompiers est enclenché et
rares sont les services publics je crois
qu'ils font montre d'une telle d'un tel
engagement et d'une telle densité de
deux missions alors cet engagement elle
reconnue par le gouvernement par la
majorité présidentielle par le président
de la république lui-même vous l'avez
cité à nombreuses reprises la loi du 25
novembre 2020 interne qui vise à
consolider notre modèle de sécurité
civile on a été un bon exemple je salue
votre engagement madame la sénatrice en
tant que rapporteur de ce texte avec vos
deux collègues loïc hervé je crois et
patrick kanner
gouvernement est déterminé à faire
paraître au plus tôt les textes
d'application de cette loi tel que vous
le demande est fort légitimement et je
peux vous dire d'ores et déjà que sur
les deux sujets d'importance que sont la
revalorisation du tarif national
d'indemnisation des carences ambulants
ambulancière
j'ai le plaisir nous indiquer que
l'arrêté interministériel qui actent
cette revalorisation à 200 euros est en
cours 2 contre st par les ministres de
l'intérieur et de la santé et gérald
darmanin s'associent évidemment à la
réponse que je suis en train de vous
faire par ailleurs le décret relatifs
merci monsieur le sénateur relatif à
l'article 2 du texte aux actes de soins
d'urgence relevant de la compétence de
sapeurs pompiers pour lequel je vous dis
donc un arbitrage sera prochainement
rendue que le décret sera ensuite sera
ensuite transmis au conseil d'état vous
en appeler au conseil d'état c'est un
décret qui sera transmis au conseil
d'état et d'ici là je peux vous assurer
que le gouvernement vous consultera vous
et les rapporteurs prochainement sur le
contenu de ce décret cet article 2 il
prévoit également kahn arrêté
interministériel précise les compétences
nécessaires les modalités de formation
des sapeurs pompiers sur la formation
elle ne sera assurée conformément au
référentiel national d'activité de
compétences d'équipier de sapeurs
pompiers professionnels et volontaires
ce qui est classiquement utilisés pour
les sapeurs pompiers comme vous le
souhaitez afin de permettre une
formation tout à la fois efficace et
rigoureuse des sapeurs pompiers mais là
mais c'est la trique j'espère avoir
répondu à vos interrogations
madame d'humour
vous nous aviez imposées vous aviez
imposer un calendrier contraint au
parlement pour que le président de la
république faire des faces puisse faire
des annonces au congrès des sapeurs
pompiers encore une fois vous êtes dans
la communication et pas dans l'action
le support limite mesdames et messieurs
les ministres merci nos prochaines
questions d'actualité auront lieu le
mercredi 2 février à 15 heures je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
16h40 pour l'examen d'une convention
internationale examiné suivants selon la
procédure d'examen simplifié
la séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance que vous venez
de suivre en direct et en intégralité
les questions au gouvernement tout de
suite c'est le débrief on va commencer
par faire un tour dans la salle des
conférences nous attend alexandre pousse
à alexandre car vous êtes avec le
président du groupe union centriste ici
au sénat le sénateur hervé marseille oui
bonjour avec marseille jours alors un
sujet important et évoquer cet après
midi c'est le scandale de maltraitance
dans les ehpad privée du groupe orpea
avec la parution est fière du livre les
fossoyeurs après une enquête de trois
ans par un journaliste est ce que selon
vous la réponse du gouvernement est à la
hauteur c'est à dire pour l'instant
c'est juste une convocation du patron de
repères mais ça va pas plus loin à
l'évidence il ya des accusations il faut
savoir si elles sont fondées ou non ce
qui est clair c'est que depuis des
années on a laissé au secteur privé le
soin de prendre en considération
le cinquième âgées il ya un problème
évident de contrôler peut-être de
l'ensemble de ces maisons de ces ehpad
et puis également de réinvestissement de
l'état on attendait une loi
effectivement il n'est pas venu et je
crois que c'est le principal sujet il
faut maintenant qu on aborde cette loi
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec votre
collègue communiste pascal sa maladie
est ce qu'il faut sortir les ehpad du
marché et voilà que des ehpad publics
non non non c'est ça c'est un autre type
de société
qui convient peut-être à mon collègue
mais enfin c'est pas c'est pas le sujet
je crois qu'il faut qu'ils aient
davantage de contrôler davantage
d'encadrement et puis surtout un texte
qui prennent en considération le
cinquième âge comme c'était annoncé
malheureusement on n'a pas vu cette loi
une vraie loi pour lutter contre la
dépendance un mot sur la hausse du prix
du carburant à la mesure annoncée hier
par jean castex de relever le barème de
l'indemnité kilométrique c'est une
mesure suffisante elle est quand même
très ciblé un pas écouter pour l'instant
on assiste beaucoup à du saupoudrage
c'est à dire qu'on a toutes sortes de
shake shake énergie cheikh inflation on
aide maintenant ceux qui roulent
beaucoup faudrait surtout moins de taxes
parce que distribuer de l'argent c'est
bien d'abord il va falloir rembourser et
puis ensuite il faut surtout moins de
taxes parce que si les prix sont élevés
c'est aussi parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
textes sur beaucoup de domaines donc
c'est plutôt une autre politique qu'il
faudrait ont fini par une question sur
les institutions c'est un sujet qui vous
tient à coeur et les xénons était
l'invité ce matin de la matinale de
public sénat il estime que notre
démocratie aujourd'hui elle est
gouvernée par les juges des juges
d'ailleurs socialiste avec laurent
fabius à la tête du conseil
constitutionnel et puis pierre moscovici
à la tête de la cour des comptes vous
êtes d'accord il ya une hyper puissance
des juges aujourd'hui hyper puissance
mais en tous les cas une part importante
a été prise dans l'espace public par les
juridictions pourquoi parce qu'il ya
plus de débat parlementaire et les gens
maintenant vont directement soit devant
le procureur soit au conseil
constitutionnel soit au conseil d'état
parce que les débats n'ont pas lieu au
parlement donc là sur les chances et de
renforcer le pouvoir du parlement voilà
merci beaucoup hervé marseille d'avoir
été au micro de public sénat merci
beaucoup alexandre pour cette première
réaction à l'issue des questions au
gouvernement et puis on va aussi parler
bien actualité internationale et
notamment et bien la question de la
crise en ukraine puisque vous allez
avoir christian cambon christian cambon
président les républicains de la
commission de la défense et des affaires
étrangères effectivement et jean yves le
drian le ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères qui s'est exprimé
cet après-midi sur la crise une
chrétienne il a parlé d'une situation
effectivement très tendue hier le
président de la république a annoncé que
la riposte serait là en cas d'invasion
russe du territoire ukrainien il a bien
fait d'évoquer à cette riposte de
montrer les muscles emmanuel macron je
pense effectivement que la cité sur en
ukraine est inquiétante à lire des
bruits de bottes de paille et de part et
d'autre plus de cent mille soldats
russes mobilisés sur la frontière et une
mobilisation aussi de soldats américains
tout ça ne sent pas très bon bien
évidemment et je pense que le président
de la république et lui des affaires
étrangères ont raison de tout faire pour
créer le dialogue ce fameux dialogue de
minsk qui est un peu perdue dans les
sables et qui aurait permis à l'europe
de 2
de se faire entendre je pense que le
président russe fait une erreur en a
c'est en ne sollicitant pas l'europe
dans ces discussions il s'agit quand
même de notre sécurité la russie est une
partie de l'europe et nous ne nous
n'allons pas voir des solutions se dit
est au dessus de nos têtes entre les
états unis et la russie donc je pense
que là c'est un véritable point nous
essayons ici vous le savez au sénat de
maintenir le dialogue avec nos collègues
russes et nous faisons passer ce genre
de message maintenant bien évidemment
souhaitons qu'un incident ne vienne pas
brutalisé une situation déjà très tendue
et en cas d'invasion russe qu'elle
pourrait être cette riposte évoqué par
emmanuel macron on a bien vu en laissant
sur les sanctions économiques contre la
demo poutine ça marche pas trop qui la
crimée a été quand même annexé en malgré
ces sanctions
très objectivement il ya un point qu'il
faut lever je pense pas que il y aura
des forces armées qui rompt
de d'un pays comme la france se bat en
ukraine je crois que l'opinion publique
ne le tolérerai pas et mouvements
américains alors c'est à part déjà par
des américains là tout est faux tout est
possible car on sait que ils ont agi de
cette manière sur d'autres théâtres
d'opération
maintenant je pense que comme toujours
et c'est le rôle du sénat ici maintenir
le dialogue toujours et partout on est
là pour agir pour la paix et il faut
utiliser tous nos moyens nous avons une
relation particulière avec les proches
du président poutine nous faisons passer
des messages pour éviter l'incident qui
embraserait l'europe centrale qui
franchement ne pas besoin une question
sur l'afrique sur la région du sahel on
a eu un hommage en débuter sur
l'actualité du président du sénat au
soldat alexandre martin qui est tombé à
gao au mali on a aussi dans le même
temps un coup d'état militaire qui est
réalisée au burkina faso où une junte
militaire au pouvoir au mali finalement
est-ce que l'opération de berkane il ne
faut pas la mettre sérieusement en
question alors je pense effectivement
qu'on arrive au temps où il faut
imaginer de nouveaux scénarios la
situation au mali est très inquiétante
la manière dont la junte malienne et
aj en remettant en cause